uno de los puentes más famosos del mundo
este que están viendo detrás de mí que
une Brooklyn con manhattany cumple hoy
140 años Fue un 24 de mayo de 1883
cuando cerca de 150.000 personas
cruzaron por primera vez este puente que
están viendo para inaugurarlo unos días
después hubo una estampida de personas
porque parece que hubo un poco de miedo
de que el puente pudiese venir abajo
venirse abajo porque estaba colgando
pero las autoridades para demostrar que
era suficientemente fuerte decidieron
que pasaran por encima del puente 21
elefantes y 17 camellos de entre 600 y
1000 kilos para demostrarle al mundo
entero que el puente de Brooklyn era
suficientemente fuerte para aguantar lo
que hiciera falta unas imágenes que
dieron la vuelta al mundo entero y lo
hicieron todavía más famoso 14 años se
tardó en construirlo pero desde luego
mereció la pena porque este puente ha
estado en muchas grandes producciones de
Hollywood Aunque hoy el protagonista es
él el que sopla las velas en ese 140
aniversario